Ось він - вірогідний канцлер Австрії,
наймолодший глава уряду не тільки в Європі,
але й у всьому світі.
31-річний Себастіан Курц сам розвалив чинний
коаліційний уряд, пішов на перевибори - і переміг.
Під його керівництвом Австрійська народна партія
отримала понад 31 відсоток голосів.
І тепер Курц оголошує себе переможцем виборів
та готується формувати свій власний уряд,
щоб стати наступним канцлером Австрії.
Сьогодні не час святкувати перемогу над іншими.
Сьогодні час розпочати справжні зміни в нашій країні.
Ми отримали беззаперечний мандат змінити
цю країну, і я дякую вам за це.
А це - сумний на невеселий нинішній канцлер Австрії.
Його Соціал-демократична партія
фінішувала тільки другою на цих виборах.
26,6 відсотків голосів - найгірший результат
партії за всю повоєнну історію.
Якби не скандал щодо кампанії чорного піару
в соціальних медіа проти конкурентів - поразка
соціал-демократів не була б настільки нищівною.
Президент доручить найсильнішій партії
сформувати уряд. А потім ми розпочнемо
цивілізовану дискусію, як найкраще забезпечити
Австрії світле майбутнє.
Для правих популістів з Австрійської партії свободи
світле майбутнє майже настало.
Вони на цих виборах - треті,
і поступаються соціал-демократам
усього однією десятою відсотка.
У них 26 з половиною відсотків голосів.
Партія свободи, яка виступає за обмеження міграції
та скасування санкцій проти Росії,
а також визнає анексію Криму,
може увійти до мабутнього коаліційного уряду.
Серед посад, що їх мають шанси отримати праві
популісти - портфель міністра закордонних справ.
Ці результати - знак високої довіри нашій партії.
Ще не все пораховано, але ми вже отримали найкращий
результат за всю історію партії, а це показує,
що люди прагнуть серйозних змін.
Партія свободи залишиться вірною собі та народу Австрії.
Яким саме буде майбутній уряд Австрії -
стане відомо вже найближчими днями.
Себастіан Курц розпочне переговори з іншими
партіями щойно офіційно оголосять остаточні результати виборів.
Якщо не вдасться домовитись про коаліцію,
молодий і амбітний майбутній канцлер вже заявив
- він готовий керувати і урядом меншості.